hello everybody and welcome to part 5 of
our NL ck with Python for natural
language processing tutorial video in
this video we're going to be talking
about chunking so what is chunking
besides a really strange sounding term
so consider you have a body of text we
know how to split it up by sentence and
by even by word and not only that but
part of speech tags we're that far what
would be the next step to figure out the
meaning of a sentence
well first we want to know who is the
sentence talking about who what whatever
and so generally we refer to that as the
named entity in the context right but
also just a noun okay so a person place
or thing is generally going to be your
subject I say generally now uh so once
you know that okay once you know the
named entity what's the next step well
the next step is going to be or the noun
the next step is going to be finding out
words that kind of modify or affect that
noun so you might have many named
entities or many nouns in the same
sentence
so you might have a sentence like a
Apple releases new phone comes with new
color case hundred dollars more and
Tesla releases home battery okay so
these are sentient this is one sentence
but it's not about two different things
completely and you might even have some
opinions in that sentence and you've got
to figure out who's where does that
opinion apply is that applying to Apple
or is that applying the Tesla so um so
that's what we're going to talk about
now is chunking and how we might be able
to do stuff like that so generally what
that's going to be is is good you're in
it most people will chunk into we're
called noun phrases and these are just
going to be groups of net will be and
down and we'll have a bunch of modifiers
around that noun and it would be kind of
like a descriptive sentence I suppose or
descriptive group of words surrounding
that now
now the downside of that is you're
you're only going to be able to use
regular expressions so what's going to
happen is you were firt be like you can
only group things together as a chunk
and it can only be a chunk of things
that are touching each other as you'll
see in a moment so that's kind of the
only downside here but you can at least
chunk important words and then kind of
break it out from there if you want it
so anyways it'll be more useful I think
to kind of visualize what chunking is
now so we're going to come down here and
the way that we do chunking is we use a
meshing of these part of speech tags and
regular expressions now if you are
unfamiliar with regular expressions you
can still follow along I'll try to
explain as good as I can but you're
going to have to brand new concepts
being thrown at you here and you may not
know which is which
like are we looking at regular
expressions here are we looking at like
chunking code so if you need to learn
about regular expressions this is a
Python per turn at net it's my website
ctrl F when you're on the basics tab
anyways if you're not here you clean and
start learning basics reg X enter we
want this one actually video tutorial
text tutorial we very fun now the main
thing that we're going to use with
chunking is modifiers so with your
modifiers you've got things like the
plus sign means it met it's one or more
question mark means zero or one
no more asterisk means zero or more so
basically any number or nothing we
probably use the dollar sign the caret
we won't be using really you might
actually probably not though the
either/or you'll use that a lot the
range you'll use as well so anyways um
just keep that in mind that's kind of
what you need to know with modifiers I
will still hold your hand through this
but like I said it might be confusing if
you if you're not familiar with either
of these concepts so coming down here
let's get rid of tagged and then we'll
go
prynt I'd rather keep tagged there now
we're ready to create our chunk Graham
Cheung Graham is going to be equal to
and generally people use triple quotes
for the shot Graham's because this one
will be really simple but a lot of times
people are going to put them and
separate them by lines because they can
get really long and complicated really
fast so chunk Graham use the triple
quotes if you want don't if you don't
want to it doesn't matter to me and
we're going to chunk by now most people
are going to put the R in front to
denote a form of regular expression here
but it e sure it's not necessary well
we'll test that if I remember - so now
chunk you can call this anything you
want you could call this up if you
wanted
it's just what it's going to be called
when it finds it so anyway a chunk
equals and then you put the chunk that
you want to you know find inside curly
braces now to bring up or mention any
form of part of speech tag use these
little round brackets sideways carrots I
don't know what the heck you call these
someone tell me what you call these and
first let's say we're looking for any
our B now what is an RB it's head over
up session let's go that's up here RB
adverb now we want to find RB RB r or r
BS any adverb we want to find how do we
do it regular expressions so we come on
down here
RB what would be a valid modifier to use
we want our be followed by basically any
character we could use the WS suppose
but we're not going to do that we're
going to say R be any character is the
period and then we're going to use a
question mark what is that so the period
is any character except for newline
basically in tabs and stuff and actually
I'm sorry it's actually any and as long
as my own tutorials correct it's
actually any character except for a new
line I thought it was also tabbed
anyways moving on RB so anything and
then question mark is 0 or 1 because as
you can see we
have any power speech tag that is longer
well at least for our be then three
characters okay but possessive pronouns
can be and they use a dirty dollar sign
there anyway moving on it's that's fine
any adverb then we're gonna say what
will say asterisk what is asterisk zero
or more
so we're saying any form of an adverb
and we're looking for zero or more of
these so this chunk will chunk whether
or not there is an adverb but if there
is one we'll get it then we'll have
another one then we're just going to be
B and then we'll use the exact same code
that we used before which is period
question mark and again if we find one
great if not no problem then we're going
to look for an n NP what's in it NP
Harrison let's go up an NP proper noun
and hot-diggity there's an example of a
proper noun it's me so come on down here
n NP we are going to require the
existence of a n NP then we're going to
do a a plausible and n let's go back up
and n is just a noun
okay so n NP singular proper noun
followed by a possible noun singular
anything now that's our chunk sweet so
hopefully you guys follow along there if
you have any questions as always ask
below now we're regular ready to do is a
parse via this chunk Graham so we're
going to say chunk parser equals n LT k
dot reg X parser and the Ray X parser we
want to use is the chunk Ram now chunk
is going to equal the chunk parser dot
parse
the tag part of speech stuff and then we
can do the phone print chumps use on a
beach but I do
reg X Oh fry sure in my original
tutorial series I swear I hid this rag X
P parser and I'm almost positive they're
doing this because it's regular
expressions and then parser but no one
says reg X they say reggae
all right anyway let's try this again
I'm almost positive that hit me in the
original tutorial this is going to go
for a while so ctrl C to break it and so
this is your you know basically out of
the output and what you're looking for
is chunk right this is chunk so chunk
state
here's another chunk Union address chunk
United capital so it's finding all these
nouns basically white house chomp-chomp
okay now this is kind of ugly the
computer loves this stuff but the human
hates it so what you can do with a LT k
if you grabbed if you have matplotlib if
you got map I live this primal work but
chumped dot draw saving run that and now
you have this look at us wow that's way
too many chumps what has happened for
them maybe because that's the start of
this practice is like this initial yeah
right so the initial stuff here that was
a little rough but anyway president
george w bush and as we can see that
really we actually would want to chunk
these all together right so maybe any
amount of n NP s so we could come down
here n NP one or more is what we want so
we want to do a plus okay so now let's
try that again i don't know how far deep
this one was but it was it was a few x's
so something like this is rerun it um
okay so that's a little better um that's
not so hot but this is hard because of
the original stuff but president george
w bush that is a correct chunk let's get
out of this initial stuff mr. speaker
vice pres Picchi
this is a tough this is a tough one for
uh python anyway we'll start on this one
so this is the original one that we
wanted to chunk for sure so president
george w bush good state of the union
again you could add this stuff into your
chunk like you could have a possible
preposition a possible I forget what DT
stands for but it's like useless words
I'm pretty sure um close close close
White House put that together
Eric Draper every time Draper I'm right
it's almost like he's missing a space
there Capitol dome that's a good catch
okay have served America alright you get
the point so this is how we're chunking
a bit of information together obviously
again like I was trying to point out our
chunk is extremely basic and as you can
see as we move forward we can think of a
lot of like little stuff that we're like
hmm I wouldn't mind adding this or that
or possible of this and so as you can
imagine these chunks can get really long
okay so anyway feel free to mess with it
I actually highly encourage you to kind
of play around with this try to catch
that of the year yeah I think it was of
the see if you can catch that and well
I'm thinking about let's look at DT
again determined
dt4 not important anyway um so that's
chunking now in the next tutorial video
we're going to talk about basically kind
of a different task now this can be
chinking and that's going to be so
chunking is the you know grouping of
things shaking is going to be the
removal of something get that out so
we'll tuck on that and the next video if
you have any questions or comments on
this video please feel free to leave
them below all otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support of subscriptions and until next
time